[Musique]
le verdict est tombé hier soir à 21h la
femme du feuilleton dans le procès
johnny depp l'actrice a été reconnu
coupable après un mois et demi de
déballage médiatique johnny depp
remporte le procès en diffamation contre
son ex compagne amber heard
est ce qu'on pensait que monsieur depp a
des preuves fiables prouvant que
mademoiselle hurd a à g avec malice la
réponse du jury et oui les jurés ont
voté à l'unanimité la condamnation dans
bird à lui verser la somme de 15
millions de dollars de dommages et
intérêts une victoire dont johnny depp
s'est réjoui sur les réseaux sociaux
remercions tous ceux qui l'avaient
soutenu six ans plus tard le jury m'a
rendu ma vie je suis réellement
reconnaissant j'espère que ma quête de
vérité on aura aidé d'autres hommes ou
femmes qui se sont retrouvés dans ma
situation un message qu'il a conclue par
le meilleur est à venir est un nouveau
chapitre commence enfin si pour l'acteur
s'est affairée derrière lui amber heard
est apparue dévasté je suis encore plus
déçu parce que ce verdict signifie pour
les autres femmes c'est un retour en
arrière à une époque où les femmes
témoignant publiquement été humilié
alors pour c'est johnny depp la
condamnation de son ex femme amber heard
fait-elle du mal aux mouvements mitu
françois durpaire qu'à quatre minutes
pour nous raconter tout ça puisque
françois doigts
et aussi il est demandé partout c'est
vrai vous est demandé partout tous les
deux on le comprend alors françois il
nous reste trois minutes alors vas-y
en fait c'est déjà c'est une grosse
surprise parce qu'en fait pour les
avocats de m on pensait ouais on pensait
que c'était facile en fait le prouver
que ben elle n'a pas diffamer dire que
même si elle avait porté des coups
même s'il y avait une relation toxique
en fait lui aussi porté des coups
puisque en fait c'est ce qu'avait dit le
juge en angleterre donc c'est un vrai
fiasco pour les avocats de lambert qui
sont passés complètement à côté et c'est
aussi une chose très claire c'est qu'en
fait c'était pas un juge en angleterre
c'était un juge et là c'était des jurés
il était pas on l'a dit hier séquestré
donc qu'ils avaient ils entendent est en
fait ce qui se passait le procès public
contrôlant board et pour répondre à la
question effectivement on parle non plus
de mis tous maintenant on entend le
hashtag mène tous les hommes aussi ça
veut dire qu'il ya de plus en plus
d'hommes qui disent mais il ya des
violences à l'intérieur du couple cela
dit mes statistiques c'est pas ça qui
montre un 90 % des victimes ce sont des
femmes sauf que là encore les chiffres
ils sont pas tout à fait exact parce que
les hommes ne portent pas plainte les
hommes n'osent pas porter plainte
évidemment c'est un procès qui est
complètement hors norme c'est quand même
que les temps changent donne juste une
indication dior a soutenu il a soutenu
jusqu'au bout puisque le parfum sauvage
on le voit encore à la télé elle finit
là pas exactement dior c'est quand même
une marque y en aurait en cas des femmes
ouais c'est une marque qui à pied
féminin qui adore jeune homme et ça
aurait pu tourner au vinaigre parce
qu'en plus sauvage on aurait pu se dire
il ya des coups à sa femme et il fait la
pub pour sauvage et serait peut être
pourri coach contre dior il n'y a pas eu
ça du tout du tout de la marque hot donc
non en fait c'est quand même le signe
quand même que les temps changent
aux etats unis alors attention
aujourd'hui on a appris que faisait
appel une possibilité d'appel et donc
c'est pas tout à fait louis d'appel sont
autant d'appels devant l'aja n'en dirait
pas mais bon c'est mal en bas c'est mal
remarque rien contre elle comme beaucoup
mal de lui donner déjà et doit lui
donner en fait 10 millions + 350
millions en fait par un
flacon temps au tour angeloni 15
millions est en fait la juge a ramené
les 5 millions de dommages et intérêts
punitifs à 350 nm c'était un peu un
fiasco hier les jurés les 20 millions à
les appeler les alliés des lions non
justement c'est ce qu'elle a dit
aujourd'hui elle a dix mois jérôme là je
fais appel j'espère que je serai entendu
parce que comment est spécial d'apa à
savoir
une deuxième fois et on dit de me donner
10 me de toute façon la même en faisant
appel doivent à doit donner environ
l'équivalent de 9000 euros un film
9009 doit donner c'est à dire que c'est
pas si c'est pas suspensif d'accord elle
va pas tant et en plus on appelle à la
trappe eu de chance quand même de
l'emporter parce qu'elle va faire comme
en france va faire une
vidéo très compliqué pour elle c'est
incroyable que des mouvements peuvent la
soutenir dire qu'on va payer maintenant
elle a été quand même lâché par beaucoup
d'associations féministes combat attendu
à suivre parce qu'ils ont senti que
c'était un peu un petit peu foireux donc
là c'est quand même assez mal embarquée
pour elle je pense quand même aux états
unis qu'il ya quand même des gens
capables de la soutenir et de pouvoir va
la payer cette somme c'est fou là
qu'elles soient en difficulté parce
qu'elle a quand même été digne dans son
vin en tout cas quand il ya eu le
verdict c'est vrai qu'on l'a tous vu au
bord des larmes et c'est évidemment
terrible pour elle se redresse imaginez
pas perdre alors cela dit elle a gagné
quand même de mieux en avignon c'est
pour ça que ça réduit un peu la serbie 2
millions
mais le johnny depp a été puni quand
même de deux millions de diffamation
inverse le seuil est de couper un petit
peu la poire en deux mais alors et le
truc sexy johnny depp il a des dominions
lui donne les dominions mais qu'elle n'a
pas les 10 millions il est du palais
dominion jerger nous donnait 8 heures et
tu bois sculpté ci lui décerna que va
devoir donner l'argent elle est la seule
belle va le toucher du jeu de mai on
vivait seul bon combat mais
huit ans et demi de
ce qu'ils dépensent un mois et dépensent
déjà plus de 2 millions
parce qu'en fait il est très dépensier
les psychiatres
ils dépensent déjà plus de 30 mille
dollars en boissons en boisson pense pas
et en boissons en alcool cola par mois
mais vous avez vu qu'il a acheté un
village dans le jeu mais qui est assez
incroyable ce qu'il a acheté il est un
band d'ailleurs encensé vous intéresse
45 millions d'euros
pardon mais je dis ça et on importe ça
suffit avec je vais t'aimer trouve où
les 45 non juristes m'intéresse de
savoir pendant l'amour ou sur le chapeau
d'un cheval
une voiture